MARK MIRCHANDANI: There are lots
of ways to host an application.
But how do you know which
makes the most sense for you
and your company?
Join us as we talk
with Thunkable
about how they made it happen
on this episode of "Stack Chat."
Mike, thanks so
much for joining us.
Can you tell us a little more
about what Thunkable does?
MIKE GALLAGHER: Sure.
Thunkable is a platform
that allows you to build
mobile apps without code.
So if you're a person
that has an idea,
and you're not an engineer,
which not everyone is,
you can snap some blocks
together, drag some components
onto the screen, and
bring your idea to life.
And we have about
half a million users
and about a million apps built.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK.
Can you tell us a
little bit about,
from the architecture
side, how Thunkable managed
the server-side application
that people then
use to build their
own applications?
MIKE GALLAGHER: Sure.
We started off with a
pretty simple architecture.
We had a small user base.
Just trying to get it out there.
So we had a single instance
connected to a cloud Mongo
and cloud Redis.
And the database is
scaled automatically,
but that single instance
led to some issues.
There was a manual deploy.
So whenever we
deployed, it went down.
And also, if you had
an unhandled exception,
it would bring down
the whole server.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I think
this is a common problem
that a lot of startups
and small teams
run into as they try to
focus on the application
and don't, unfortunately,
spend as much time
on the infrastructure.
How did your team choose
to address these problems?
MIKE GALLAGHER:
We pretty quickly
realized we needed
multiple instances,
so we spun up a couple more.
But we were still
doing manual deploys.
And so now we had
to do three of them.
And it was great that we
had less downtime-- that's
super important-- and that the
exceptions weren't taking down
the entire service, but it
was taking too much time.
So we quickly went
to a Docker build,
which allowed us to
automated build that we
can build on our own machines.
We'd push it to Google
Cloud, and then just
deploy it to each of
the instances manually.
And then shortly after that,
we realized that Kubernetes
could do this for us.
So we just allow Kubernetes
to deploy our images to as
many instances as we need.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So now you're
using managed infrastructure.
And you get all the
benefits of that,
but it sounds like you're
still doing the build manually.
MIKE GALLAGHER: Correct.
It took about a half an
on our local machines.
So we took a look at a Google
Cloud Build, and we got it up
and running there.
And it wasn't
necessarily faster,
but we weren't
sitting there watching
it, which is basically faster.
So the other thing was
before, we weren't exactly
sure what was on production.
It was kind of up
to us to make sure
that we deployed
the right stuff.
But now we just tag
our master branch,
and then Google Cloud Build
kicks off and deploys it
to our staging environment.
So it's quite a bit easier.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it
sounds like your team
learned a lot over time and
then implemented those changes.
But if you knew everything you
knew now back then, what would
you have done differently?
MIKE GALLAGHER: The first thing
I definitely would have done
was just started with
Docker and Kubernetes.
It was nice to live through
the pain points that it solved,
but I could have watched
a three-minute video.
One thing we did do right
was every few weeks,
we'd look at our DevOps process
and see where our pain points
were and try to address them.
And some of the things
that we've fixed recently
is our Docker build, we've
added Docker layer caching,
so that we can speed up
our builds from, like, 30
minutes to five minutes if
it's just a quick back end fix.
So that's been really helpful.
The other thing is making
our Docker image much smaller
has led to faster employments.
And we did that with
multi-stage builds,
which allow the final
product to have just what it
needs to run in production.
And having faster deploys
is really important
when you're constantly
pushing things
and want the ability
to quickly deploy
a hot fix or new features.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank you
so much for coming in here
and telling us about how your
team navigated both maintaining
the application and
improving the infrastructure
at the same time.
MIKE GALLAGHER: Any time.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Want to
try using Google Cloud Build
and Kubernetes for yourself?
Check out the tutorial
in the description
to get some hands-on experience.
Thanks for watching.
And make sure to subscribe
for more great Google Cloud
Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]